[Musique]
la nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique sur
tv 78 est dédié à ces municipales 2020
merci de nous rejoindre je reçois
aujourd'hui philippe guillen bienvenue
sur ce plateau
merci tête de liste les claies avec vos
listes de sensibilité de centre droit
mais plutôt sans étiquette divers droite
sans étiquette
ce n'est pas l'essentiel pour vous c'est
que vous allez faire passer c'est pas
l'essentiel effectivement néanmoins moi
personnellement je suis de sensibilité
centre-droit je ne suis pas encarté
nous avons très peu de personnes
encartées dans la liste globalement
c'est une sensibilité centre droit mais
également une liste plurielle avec
d'autres sensibilités ce qui compte pour
nous c'est le projet mais comme nous
avons l'habitude de le dire notre parti
c'est notre ville la ville des
clayes-sous-bois qui aura quoiqu'il
arrive un nouveau maire en mars prochain
véronique côté millard ne va pas briguer
un nouveau mandat elle s'en est
expliquée déjà mais vous avez fait
partie de sa majorité en tant que
premier adjoint aux finances vous en
fais toujours partie d'ailleurs son
bilan vous l'assumez au moins en partie
exact je fais partie de l'équipe de
véronique côté millard depuis 2001 donc
trois mandats dont trois mandats en tant
qu'avion finances demanda en tant que
premier adjoint est effectivement très
très globalement j'assume le mandat qui
a été réalisé depuis deux mille ans les
mandats
vous êtes élu depuis 18 ans donc sur
cette commune pourquoi aujourd'hui
vouloir prendre la tête de cette commune
alors pourquoi aujourd'hui parce que
aujourd'hui j'en ai encore envie j'en ai
la possibilité en tant que disponibilité
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant et puis
véronique côté millard était tête de
liste dont il n'y avait aucune velléité
de ma part de me présenter contre contre
elle
aujourd'hui j'ai également autour de moi
pu réunir la majorité des adjoints et
conseillers municipaux de l'équipe de
l'équipe actuelle donc voilà pourquoi je
me suis
lancé dès mars 2019 dans cette aventure
mais pour autant vous n'avez pas le
soutien ni côté millard la maire
sortante qui a décidé de la corde et une
autre une autre de ses ancienne
colistière et qui faisait partie de la
même majorité en clair frémont c'est un
regret aujourd'hui la situation est un
peu particulière
exact c'est très surprenant dans la
mesure où j'ai été son premier adjoint
donc pendant pendant deux ans de mandat
dans la mesure où j'ai la majorité des
adjoints et conseillers municipaux
elle ne donne pas sa préférence à cette
majorité bon ceci dit c'est ce n'est pas
notre souci à nous notre souci c'est le
projet et l'avenir votre liste
aujourd'hui et complète vous l'avez dit
vous avez repris une partie de la
majorité mais pas toutes non parce que
l'objectif également était de renouveler
de renouveler et de cocher toutes les
diversités et toutes les sensibilités
ainsi que tous les quartiers de notre
commune des clayes-sous-bois donc c'est
pour ça que nous repartirons à onze ou
douze de l'ancien de l'ancienne majorité
et tout le reste sera complétée par des
niveaux aussi bien des seniors que des
jeunes
j'en viens à vous précisément que vous
disiez plus de disponibilité vous êtes
retraité d'airbus ancien directeur
financier et vous dites les maires
seront à l'avenir des gestionnaires
c'est un profil qui vous conviendrait
plus mais alors pourquoi gestionnaire
aujourd'hui cercle maire va être là pour
surtout faire attention finances alors
le lot mer dans la dans les années à
venir devra effectivement faire
attention aux finances comme nous avons
dû le faire par le passé
d'ailleurs madame côté millard m'a fait
entièrement confiance sur ce domaine
depuis depuis 2001 ou lorsque le maire
avait repris la commune elle était quand
même dans une situation plus que plus
que précaire on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons une situation une situation
saine dans l'avenir
les dotations de la part de l'état sont
en comptant en constante diminution
il est donc nécessaire de faire très
attention de mutualiser et de s'appuyer
sur nos partenaires des partenaires nous
en avons
fort heureusement un très important au
niveau de notre agglomération qui est
saint quentin en yvelines
nous avons également le département nous
avons également la région et il sera
important par la suite que tous les
maires s'appuie sur tous ses partenaires
et j'ai la chance d'être en très bonne
entente et en appui avec tous ses
partenaires les agglomérations qui ont
justement de plus en plus de pouvoir sur
sur les communes de plus en plus de
délégations leur sont leur sont conférés
saint quentin en yvelines les
clayes-sous-bois la ville est arrivé au
sein de saint quentin en yvelines au
cours de ce dernier mandat justement
comment s'est passée cette intégration
alors cette intégration comme dans toute
intégration il ya du positif et du
négatif personnellement moi j'estime
qu'il y a beaucoup de positif
néanmoins il faudra par la suite que les
maires des communes puissent continuer à
bien se faire entendre au niveau d'une
d'une agglomération notamment pour tout
ce qui est proximité ceci dit il faut
quand même pas oublier tous que saint
quentin en yvelines et la deuxième
agglomération en france avec le 2ème pib
en france avec toutes les ressources
financières que qui se déclinent
derrière et ses ressources se traduisent
par des compléments de financement pour
nos communes aussi bien dans le
fonctionnement que dans l'investissement
et ça pour l'avenir dans les temps qui
arrive c'est très important
j'en viens à vos points de programme
vous dites être plus à l'écouté de la
population à des instances de démocratie
participative notamment la quelle que
soit la commune il ya une forte attente
justement des citoyens de retrouver la
parole et de s'exprimer
beaucoup de candidats disent justement
mettre en place la démocratie
participative si vous êtes élu ça va
passer par quoi alors effectivement
beaucoup de candidats décident de
le mettre en place certainement parce
que par le passé ça ne veut pas été
assez mis assez mis en avant c'était le
cas au niveau des clayes sous bois où
nous n'avions par exemple plus de
comités de quartier or l'information
aujourd'hui ne doit pas être uniquement
descendante de la part des élus mais
elle doit être descendante remontantes
expliqué comprise et ensuite approuvé
globalement ça veut dire des
concertations régulièrement et veut dire
des concertations régulièrement pas tous
les mois passent systématiquement sur un
projet metrolinx a exactement élus sur
sur un projet mais il doit y avoir des
des points de deux rencontres très très
réguliers avec les comités de quartier
avec la population sur tous les grands
projets et les grands projets c'est
aussi la maîtrise du développement
urbain c'est l'effet est là aujourd'hui
vous dites il faut revoir ce pays et lui
voir un petit peu les constructions à
l'avenir le développement de cette ville
déclarait il faut il faut maîtriser à
l'avenir tout ce qui va se faire au
niveau construction c'est pour ça que
toutes les constructions sur les crises
voix sur les mandats leur beaucoup
d'urbanisation on peut penser qu'il y
beaucoup de constructions
néanmoins la population était en légère
baisse c'est aussi cela qui est
contradictoire
donc ça veut dire que il faut des
constructions mais tout cela doit être
maîtrisée puisque au niveau des
clayes-sous-bois la population a
conservé son esprit village et
personnellement je souhaite je souhaite
également le conserver garder cet esprit
village au sein d'une agglomération
comme ça on y voit aussi un d'une
agglomération est difficile non non ça
ça ça peut se faire mais ça peut se
faire
je reprends les différents points de
programme qui ont été élaborées jusqu'à
présent même si et bien évidemment comme
pour l'ensemble des candidats que nous
recevons en ce moment le programme est
encore en cours d'élaboration le scrutin
se déroulera le 15 mars
parlons de santé parce qu'il ya aussi
cette problématique et qui revient sur
toutes les communes essaient d'attirer
les professionnels de santé créé des
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
c'est souvent la solution qui est avancé
mais ensuite il faut trouver les
professionnels pour les faire venir vos
voisins de plaisir on cette difficulté
par exemple comment vous vous pourrez
répondre à cette problématique là vous
souhaitez cette maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire
alors effectivement je sais que
notre collègue de plaisir à cette
difficulté néanmoins c'est pas parce
qu'il ya une difficulté qu'on doit
abandonner jeu mais ceci à mon programme
je sais que cela mettra du temps à le
réaliser
nous le réaliserons en accord avec les
professionnels de santé de la commune
j'ai discuté avec certains médecins qui
m'ont effectivement fait état des
difficultés de recrutement
mais nous pouvons avoir des supports au
niveau du département au niveau de
l'agglomération et cet objectif de
maison pluridisciplinaire a été
couronnée de succès dans une ville de
l'agglomération qui est montigny le
bretonneux
donc pourquoi pas au clair avec l'appui
aussi de la faculté médecine 1 qui se
trouve juste à côté mais qui fait partie
de saint quentin en yvelines
comme vous avez travaillé au sein d'une
agglomération effectivement faculté
médecine bon que je connais un petit peu
dans la mesure où je suis déléguée aux
universités dans le cadre de
l'agglomération et nous avons un très
très beau projet d'extension de cette
faculté de médecine avec l'équivalent
d'un hôpital virtuel et peut-être que
dans ce cadre là également il peut y
avoir des convergences avec les communes
pour terminer très rapidement prochaine
réunion prochaine prochain rendez vous
pour votre campagne à partir du mois de
janvier nous feront de nouveau des
réunions avec
la population nous en avons déjà fait 6
la prochaine se dérouleront au courant
janvier
merci à yves reverseau 7,8 politiques
candidats les clés avec vous je rappelle
aussi que sur cette ville se présentent
nicolas eu avec la liste de gauche à un
autre projet pour les clés et
anne-claire frémont soutenu notamment
par la république en marche avec elle
les clayes-sous-bois c'est vous le 7 8
politique se poursuit et direction
plaisir ou à la maire sortante joséphine
coleman berger vient d'annoncer sa
candidature elle brigue un nouveau
mandat satisfaite de son bilan l annonce
que son programme est en cours de
finalisation
il portera les aspirations des habitants
entendu ces derniers mois et on les
écoute plus en détail justement au micro
de nicolas d'andry il ya un bilan
important qui a été fait par l'ensemble
des équipes sur une mandature complète
et ce bilan mérite aujourd'hui je pense
véritablement d'être continuer nous
avons mis en place deux grands projets
qui sont des projets structurants de la
collectivité
cette dynamique il faut la continuer
mais en même temps on a entendu que ce
désir de bien-être de ville nature de
ville humaine de ville également
entreprenante et puis de ville aussi
responsable tous ces mots ce sont des
mots former des mots que l'on retrouve
aujourd'hui dans une vraie volonté notre
population et face à la maire sortante
on retrouve son ancien adjoint à patrick
inter avec la liste remettons plaisir en
marche il tiendra une réunion publique
le 6 février à 20 heures salle des et
cathine villepreux une liste citoyenne
se présente également pour le scrutin à
venir une liste portée par valérie à ben
qui se dit citoyenne ouverte pluriel
participative deux conseillers
municipaux d'opposition sans étiquette
l'ont rejointe dans son projet
l'urbanisation avec notamment la volonté
de mettre en place un moratoire sur tous
les programmes immobiliers qui n'ont pas
encore été lancés ou encore un
renforcement du lien entre les
associations et la programmation
culturelle de la ville ainsi que
l'attrait de commerce pour dynamiser le
centre ville
elle nous passons à présent à quelques
dates de rendez vous d'agenda de
campagne avec renault en vieux tête de
liste vivre versailles il organise un
diagnostic en marche
c'est un rendez-vous dans le quartier
est saint louis le 11 janvier à 11
heures pour évoquer les difficultés de
mobilité d'aménagement ou encore de
propreté renault en dieu mène à 56 ans
une liste qui se veut écologique et
indépendante
il est engagé auprès de plusieurs
associations de la commune et puis à
rambouillet véronique matillon elle mène
la liste rambouillet ensemble vers
l'avenir une liste sans étiquette
réunion publique à 20 heures le 31
janvier véronique matillon actuelle
adjointe aux affaires scolaires et
familiales qui représentera la majorité
sortante le maire l'est républicain marc
robert ne se représentant pas pour des
raisons de santé
la campagne des municipales dans les
yvelines est à suivre au quotidien dans
le journal de la rédaction en direct à
18h l'intégralité des replays ville par
ville sont à consulter sur notre site
internet
quant aux 7,8 politique il revient le
mardi est 7 janvier 18h 45 en direct sur
cette antenne très belle soirée
[Musique]